Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Cecilia Bernabeni
[Azione chiama, genera,
crea, ispira azione]
[Il conto alla rovescia
non lascia scampo]
[Possiamo fermare
il cambiamento climatico]
Buongiorno a tutti.
È possibile vivere bene, e prosperare,
in un mondo e in un territorio
che sia "carbon neutral",
cioè dove le emissioni
dei nostri gas serra, provocate da noi,
siano assorbite dalle foreste locali?
Ci chiede questa cosa troppe rinunce,
oppure il costo di non fare niente
è ancora più alto
di quello che sarebbe rimanere -
cercare di migliorare in questo senso?
Be', una delle cose
che mi ha colpito di più,
in questo periodo,
è stato il fatto che degli economisti,
anche piuttosto importanti,
sono usciti con delle frasi
che sono state appunto -
che hanno cercato di chiarire
un po' la situazione:
che il potenziale fallimento
delle politiche di mitigazione
e di adattamento ai cambiamenti climatici
sono il rischio numero uno per impatto,
e il numero due per probabilità,
nei prossimi dieci anni,
per lo sviluppo economico.
E allora, sapete appunto magari
l'impegno dell'Europa entro il 2050
a essere carbon neutral.
Ma ci sono delle città
anche importanti, anche molto grandi,
che hanno preso degli impegni
importanti, per l'appunto,
per cercare di arrivare
ancora prima a questi traguardi.
Però, quello che forse non sapete
è che c'è un territorio,
la provincia di Siena,
che ci è già arrivato.
Ci è arrivato nel 2011,
e vi faccio vedere come.
Questa è una storia che comincia
nel 2006, praticamente,
e in cui il nostro gruppo di ricerca
è stato chiamato a fare, appunto,
il bilancio dei gas serra della Provincia.
Nel 2008, il primo bilancio
è stato certificato
secondo lo standard
internazionale ISO 14064.
E in grigio vedete le emissioni,
in verde gli assorbimenti;
e vedete appunto che, nel primo anno,
le emissioni eccedevano
rispetto agli assorbimenti,
che rappresentavano il 72 percento,
appunto, di quello che erano le emissioni.
Ora, immaginatevi la scena:
io presento questa cosa -
di cui, appunto, c'era
un elemento di novità molto importante
perché eravamo, a quello che sappiamo,
i primi al mondo
ad avere un bilancio
certificato per un territorio -
e il presidente della Provincia di allora,
preso dall'entusiasmo,
dice: "OK, bene.
Visto il risultato brillante,
noi vogliamo diventare
'carbon neutral' entro il 2015".
Ecco: io, in quel momento,
mi sono sentito male.
Mentre tutti applaudivano io -
non so, mi sono visto un film davanti:
avete presente quando uno guida,
la macchina non va
e prende a cazzotti il volante?
Ecco: io, in quel momento,
mi sentivo il volante.
(Risate)
Per fortuna, però, le cose, diciamo,
non sono andate troppo male:
anzi, sono andate decisamente bene
perché si è innescato un circolo virtuoso.
Perché la Provincia ha deciso,
in questo periodo,
di non fondare le sue politiche
solo su misurazioni che riguardavano
soltanto gli elementi economici,
usando l'euro come
indicatore fondamentale.
Ma ha deciso di utilizzare
anche un indicatore "strano":
le tonnellate di CO2 equivalente.
Ed ecco allora che in quel periodo,
appunto, in questo periodo di tempo,
la Provincia non ha solo fornito
i dati per essere analizzata,
ma ha anche formulato delle politiche;
e poi, il nostro gruppo di ricerca
è stato quello che ha fatto il bilancio
e ha anche misurato
la bontà delle politiche
con, appunto, indicatori.
Il tutto, appunto,
verificato come correttezza
per dati e per metodologia.
E di politiche fatte, in questi anni,
ce ne sono state parecchie.
Ad esempio, parto da quelle più eclatanti:
un Piano Energetico Provinciale
che ha portato all'indipendenza
per l'energia elettrica
della provincia di Siena.
Prima importava l'energia elettrica:
dopo, ha cominciato ad esportarla.
Questo grazie a un aumento cospicuo
delle energie rinnovabili,
e della parte geotermica.
Un piano di rifiuti che ha portato
da più di 40 discariche a una,
e che ha visto un allargamento,
e un ampliamento, del termovalorizzatore
che ha contribuito ulteriormente, appunto,
all'indipendenza dell'energia elettrica.
Anche cose molto più piccole:
è stata imposta una revisione
annuale delle caldaie.
E questa cosa "piccola",
che è stata vissuta da molti cittadini
come una vessazione,
in realtà alla fine di questo periodo
abbiamo verificato che ha portato
a un 30 percento in meno
dei consumi di metano.
100 euro ben spesi
da ciascun cittadino, ogni anno.
E nel periodo, anche,
l'effettiva estensione forestale,
grazie a una politica
di protezione delle foreste,
e anche a una maggiore
protezione dagli incendi,
ha visto un quasi 20 percento
di aumento delle foreste.
E questo appunto, vedete, nel tempo,
quello che è successo al bilancio.
E dal 2011 la linea gialla,
che è quella del bilancio netto
è passata dalla parte verde,
è passata dalla parte degli assorbimenti,
e non da quella delle emissioni.
E vedete come, più o meno,
rimanga costante o quasi,
con lievi oscillazioni, ogni anno.
Tenete conto che, in questo periodo,
il PIL della provincia
è aumentato del 20 percento.
Quindi vedete che,
a proposito di rinunce gravi,
non è proprio necessario farne.
Quindi ha funzionato tutto benissimo?
Eh, sì e no:
ha funzionato tutto bene
per quello che riguarda i risultati;
non ha funzionato altrettanto bene
la comunicazione.
Perché tutt'oggi, quando andiamo in giro
a raccontare - anche a Siena -
che la Provincia è "carbon neutral",
vediamo queste facce.
Ringrazio i collaboratori più giovani,
che si son prestati a questa gag.
Perché sono, diciamo,
nella migliore delle ipotesi stupiti:
altrimenti, completamente scettici.
E diciamo, a simboleggiare
e a cercare di sollecitare
anche le autorità
a fare un po' più di comunicazione,
quando andavo a presentare i bilanci
mettevo sempre questa diapositiva
chiedendo: "Dove è stata
scattata, questa foto?"
E le risposte erano sempre:
"Ah, in quella località",
"quell'altra località", eccetera.
La risposta era che questa foto
non è stata scattata da nessuna parte,
perché questo è un fotoinserimento
fatto da noi del gruppo
mettendo appunto, con Photoshop,
un cartello che non c'è.
Quindi diciamo che, in questo periodo,
abbiamo capito appunto
che cosa non ha funzionato:
un progetto completamente "top down",
che ha visto appunto i cittadini
partecipare in forma molto limitata;
e anzi, a subire qualche volta
le cose che venivano fatte.
Abbiamo deciso di ribaltarlo,
questo approccio:
siamo passati a un concetto diverso,
che è quello di "Alleanza Territoriale".
Simile all'Alleanza
per lo sviluppo sostenibile,
ispirata a quell'idea lì.
In cui, appunto, non c'è qualcuno
che impone di fare qualcosa,
ma ci sono alleati che decidono
di fare qualcosa in più
per migliorare ulteriormente
la situazione.
L'idea dell'Alleanza
è quella di far conoscere,
meglio possibile,
cosa è successo e quali sono
le caratteristiche del territorio
che permettono che questo sia successo.
Sensibilizzare la partecipazione
e anche, diciamo,
avere un moto di orgoglio:
pensate che, a oggi,
non c'è nessuna azienda
in provincia di Siena
che usa il fatto di essere
"carbon neutral" nel proprio marketing.
Neanche una!
Sensibilizzare la partecipazione,
e creare un moto di orgoglio,
potrebbe andare appunto in questo senso.
Questi due fattori, poi,
sono quelli che saranno decisivi
per consolidare,
nel lungo periodo, il risultato.
Poi ci siamo detti anche
che, tutto sommato, potevamo essere
di esempio per altri territori.
Perché il nostro percorso l'abbiamo fatto:
abbiamo fatto le nostre cose buone
e le nostre cose cattive,
quelle che non hanno funzionato;
per cui abbiamo
da raccontarle, queste cose.
Ma prima di vedere questo aspetto
sull'esportabilità del nostro progetto,
facciamo un'altra piccola zoomata
e vediamo che cosa succede
nel territorio della provincia di Siena.
Sono le zone verdi, ovviamente,
che sono quelle in cui si assorbe di più.
Quelle rosse, in cui si emette.
Ovviamente questo chiama, anche,
a diverse politiche da fare,
ovviamente, sulle zone verdi,
magari verdichiare o bianche,
c'è da cercare magari di aumentare
la copertura boschiva:
su quelle rosse, c'è da fare operazioni
magari sì, anche di arredo urbano
e di alberi in città, che sono importanti:
però ci sono anche altre cose
più importanti da fare.
E se zoomiamo ancora su Siena,
vediamo che il 28% delle emissioni
arrivano dalla città di Siena,
di tutta la provincia -
ma solo il due percento
degli assorbimenti.
E vi faccio vedere un po' un attimo
come potrebbe funzionare un percorso
di decarbonizzazione della città.
Qui vedete, nella parte rossa,
il Comune di Siena reale;
la parte in verde, invece,
è la foresta che ci vorrebbe
per compensare le emissioni
del Comune di Siena.
Nella parte bassa, in verdechiaro,
ci sono invece le aree verdi
veramente esistenti.
E abbiamo anche attribuito le emissioni
ai vari settori energetici, dei trasporti,
all'agricoltura e così via,
tra i rifiuti -
e qui li abbiamo anche colorati
per farveli vedere meglio.
A questo punto, possiamo cominciare
a vedere come decarbonizzare -
che cosa fare per decarbonizzare.
Ecco: se togliamo le emissioni
che sono assorbite localmente,
dalle aree verdi esistenti,
abbiamo visto sparire
un pezzetto alla base,
che riguardava l'agricoltura,
e quasi tutta la parte dei rifiuti solidi.
Se decidiamo di cambiare
tutte le nostre lampadine,
e di averle tutte a LED
invece che con una tecnologia vecchia,
vedrete che in cima
sparirà un pezzo del buco.
Se poi, invece, cominciamo
a usare i tetti dei capannoni
delle zone artigianali e industriali
della periferia di Siena,
si vede che sparisce un altro bel pezzo.
E questa cosa potrebbe andare avanti,
con politiche sulla
coibentazione delle case
che porterebbe a un bel, diciamo,
a una bella riduzione
della parte arancione:
e così via, fino ad arrivare
alla neutralità.
L'abbiamo già fatto,
e possiamo farlo anche in questo caso.
Quindi, il modello è esportabile?
Sì, è esportabile tutto:
sia nella prima parte, diciamo,
che è condotta dalla
neutralità di carbonio;
sia in quest'ultimo pezzo qua.
Perché è vero che la Provincia di Siena
ha caratteristiche peculiari:
la bassa popolazione,
la bassa densità di popolazione,
un largo territorio,
la presenza della geotermia;
però questo fatto ha inciso
soprattutto nella prima parte.
Non ha inciso particolarmente
nella parte di miglioramento,
che è stata appunto, in pochi anni,
dal 72 al 108 percento.
E questo senza l'aiuto
della popolazione, in un certo senso,
che ha subìto questo pezzo di percorso.
E quindi, se si coinvolge
dall'inizio la popolazione,
possiamo avere risultati ancora migliori
di quelli che ha avuto Siena
in questo percorso.
E credo che sia appunto
completamente esportabile,
e non visionario,
pensare di dimezzare
le emissioni nel 2030.
E come ultima cosa, un bilancio:
cosa abbiamo? Che cosa ci manca?
Quello che abbiamo, fino ad oggi,
è la conoscenza per fare un'analisi.
Sono i dati.
La maggior parte dei dati
a disposizione per fare politiche
ce li abbiamo già.
Capacità tecnologica?
C'è: non c'è dubbio,
e lo vedremo anche più tardi.
Capacità di pianificare?
C'è, anche questa: in questo
ultimo periodo, specialmente,
i nostri pianificatori hanno cominciato
a pensare alle nostre città
in maniera molto diversa da oggi.
Cosa manca?
Manca una conoscenza,
e una coscienza diffusa,
e una consapevolezza che questi problemi
siano urgenti e importanti.
Lo sono: lo hanno detto gli economisti
all'inizio della mia presentazione.
Un ingaggio maggiore
del sistema produttivo,
perché ci sono solo pochi front runners
che fanno, in questa direzione,
delle cose veramente importanti;
e una leadership politica
che conduca a delle azioni importanti.
Perché solo dall'unione di cittadini,
amministratori e imprese
possiamo pensare di supportare
tutti i cambiamenti che sono necessari
per azzerare la CO2 dei nostri territori
e far partire uno sviluppo che sia basato
sulla qualità dell'ambiente,
e non basato sul saccheggio dell'ambiente.
E poi, la cosa che vorrei
veramente che succedesse
è che queste esperienze,
tutte le esperienze che stanno partendo,
venissero messe in condivisione,
perché nessuno debba reinventarsi
il percorso daccapo.
Ci sono degli iter amministrativi,
delle idee che devono essere appunto
messe in condivisione fra tutti,
perché insieme è meglio che da soli.
Noi abbiamo dovuto, in questo senso,
aprire un sentiero,
ma creare una rete
di territori "carbon neutral"
penso che sarà uno step molto,
molto importante da fare nel futuro.
Perché sta partendo Parma,
in questa direzione;
sta partendo Bologna;
sta partendo Belluno.
E quindi, mettere insieme
tutte queste esperienze
può essere veramente la svolta
per far sì che i nostri territori
diventino davvero "Carbon Neutral".
Grazie.
(Applausi)